this is Startalk okay wide citizen of
the wide world Chuck what's our next
query here we go now this might be
another conflation however I know where
he is coming from and this is Jason
Harvey coming to us from Twitter and
Jason would like to know this can we 3d
print an animal and then and then then
he goes a little crazy and then started
up with an electric shock
the villagers why are they out there
with pitchforks and torches the doc doc
Frankenstein there so everybody wanted
to pet the rabbit it's very reasonable
to me that people will be able to 3d
print someday DNA
you'd make a synthetic organism holy
crap whether you'd build a whole woolly
mammoth from scratch or 3d printer that
might be harder but that's a little
mind-blowing what you're saying right
there I'm just saying that because
people are talking about it it's it's so
and you don't mean like a model of the
3d if I'm making a virus its molecular
machine printer gizmo and then making a
single cell right and then fusing it and
having it grow into a mammoth or a chuck
believe me you went to Mammoth before
you went to chop no I believe there's
another one of these things where I
would like to talk it over with Chuck's
wife get up every show Oh believe me he
would prefer a mammoth he would prefer a
mammoth over another Chuck yeah yeah and
probably much easier to care for yes yes
lower maintenance lower maintenance more
logical and probably sheds less than I
do I can hear you a lot of information
little do much Chuck this
is Startalk